whether you're trying to book a car
rental for vacation or perhaps need a
car while yours is being fixed well
you've probably found it's tough to find
one without spending a fortune that's
right our very own madison kimbrough
spoke with a company giving people an
alternative to rental car process
[Music]
it definitely was not easy i would say
they maybe had too many vans left and
when i looked elsewhere in other
sites like avis or other ones they
didn't have any minivans as summer
travel approaches locals like adele
newberry says she just needed a ride for
her and her kids while their car was in
the shop every time i looked it got
higher and higher so whenever i switched
platforms the price would go down and
she's not alone as the process to find a
rental car on a week's notice has become
a challenge with many having to book it
out months in advance so that's where
companies like turo steps in described
as the world's largest car sharing
marketplace guests have the option to
choose from a selection of over 1300
makes and models we're in well over 7
500 cities including
las vegas
where you can book from local hosts
prices vary but finding an affordable
and available car on a week's notice is
very possible mikey del rosario recalls
using the service just after lockdown
during the pandemic and says it helped
him out so much that he decided to
become a host himself it's been going
really well actually it's booked like
almost every day
i love driving the car and sometimes i'm
like oh man it's booked again madison
kimbrough live local now